- The reason I'm passionate
about explainability
is because as a creator of
these kinds of AI systems,
you know, there is responsibility
that we have in sort of figuring out
when they might go wrong.
A lot of our lives today are governed
by these narrow AI systems
that already work quite well
in the narrow domain in
which they are built.
But how do we govern them?
And I think that's an important problem
for our age that we need to try and solve.
So I believe there are these
five interesting questions
that we have to begin to answer,
which is, is the input data biased?
So if the input to a machine
learning system is biased,
or if it's incorrect,
or if it has a blind
spot in a certain area,
how do we detect it and how do we fix it?
The second is, is a model
making systematic errors?
So is it the case that, you know,
whenever it's raining outside,
the model's just showing me
weird news on Google news,
that doesn't happen,
but that's the kind of thing
you would like to know.
How certain are we about the model
in the regime of the input data?
So, I have a model, for example,
a mortgage model at a bank,
and it's making decisions.
But a new type of lender has
started applying for my model.
Maybe because there's an
economic shift or a social shift.
If the old model is not valid anymore,
How do I know that it's actually
making good calls or not?
Can you explain the
logic behind the model?
So generally, the answer is no.
So but then what can you do?
What's the next best thing you can do?
And how do we detect
regimes we have missing data
and how do we gather it?
So let me give you a few
examples of these problems.
The first one is the input data biased?
This is a generally
pretty depressing study.
The data is available on CDC.
And so what this data is,
you know for every hospital visit,
when somebody goes into triage in the ER,
you know there is that model that's done
to figure out how acute is this.
Should we look at it right
away, or can they wait?
And so that's called the triage model.
And what you see is on
top the same network
of the same data, it's colored
by the predicted mortality of the model.
And at the bottom it's colored
by the actual mortality that you see.
So you will see a couple
of things in this,
the first thing that you can
see is that generally speaking,
the model does a fine enough job right?
Generally speaking we'll see
more band mortality towards
the right journey the model
is making those predictions it's fine.
The second thing that you will notice
is that the model is very optimistic.
Right, the model is very
regular and very optimistic.
There are lots of places
here that are certainly
at the bottom yellowish,
that the model is.
Yeah, it's blue, it's happy, it's fine.
The one particular area
that I want to point out
is circle up here which is the model says
it's totally fine no problem
and those people all end
up basically not surviving.
They are experience so
the question is why?
It turned out that these
people were delirious enough
that they couldn't answer a
few questions on the survey.
Some missing data was causing
this problem in the model, right?
So this is an example
of how do we detect bias
in the input data to the models
where we can then go
hopefully correct it either
in some human way or process
or in some systematic way.
Second example is the model
making systematic errors.
This is an example from a fighter jet.
If you've read the news recently,
the F30 and F16 programs
aren't doing amazingly well.
And one of the major reasons
is that a lot of pilots
in these systems are
having hypoxia events.
And what that means is when
they're flying the plane
all of a sudden they're
they become unconscious
and when they we know,
when they eventually land,
it turns out that they had
a severe lack of oxygen
for a small amount of time
that led them to becoming unconscious.
Now obviously this is not lost on anybody
not on Lockheed, not on Boeing,
not on the Air Force itself.
So the question is you know,
what are they doing about it.
And to their credit they've installed lots
and lots and lots of sensors in the plane.
So in fact, a plane today collects
about a terabyte of data every minute
from all these sensors right.
Now again the obvious problem,
when you collect a lot of data
is how do you know when,
you know how do you know that
when do you know the
data is actually pointing
to something useful or not.
And similar to the compliance thing
that I talked about earlier,
in this case 99% of those
cases are just false alerts.
They are alerts that happen,
where you alert on every single variable.
So for example the thrust of the plane
is too—I'm making this up—
but the thrust of the plane is too high.
So you are alerting on it.
But it's not really meaningful.
The things that lead to these weird events
are combinations of events
that you have to find.
So in this example, you know,
you discover the systematic errors
that the false alarm model is making,
and then you expose it to,
through a user experience that is
usable by a domain expert.
So that a domain expert, you know,
who wants to get to the root cause
is able to figure out the root cause
and fix the problem or root cause.
So this is the example in
figuring out systematic errors.
The third is how certain
are we about the model
in the input regime of the data?
So, we've created a model
and so this case, this is a
financial stress test model.
And we want to figure out
which variables are the most important
and just speeding up a little bit
just looking at the time here.
So I'll go quickly through this.
But again the case here
is that for every time you
get an input to the model,
you can place it on the model
that you created in the
back end, this topological map.
And you can figure out: is it a region
of high certainty or not?
So at least you can attach estimates
to every prediction that
you make individually.
And say that hey, if I'm recommending
this news article to somebody,
you know, what is my estimate
that I will be correct in this prediction?
So I think it's a really important ability
for models to have to do that.
Finally, the second last example here
is how do we explain the
logic behind the model?
So this is a picture of Alvin,
for people in the machine
learning community,
this was the first time we built kind
of a self driving machine.
And it worked pretty well actually.
Right, it worked amazingly well,
for the time; it had a camera system
and a cell drive system and all that.
It turned out that you know,
they built this over the fall,
they built it really really quickly.
And when they tested it
on the first day of
summer, it didn't work.
So the question was why,
why is it not working?
And it turned out that
the model had learned
to basically see the sky as being gray.
So if the sky was blue,
the model was like what just happened?
You know, I don't know what to do anymore.
So today, in our image detection systems,
we run very more complicated models.
So this is a deep learning model
for people who've seen the
news recently deep learning
is making all sorts of waves
in perception problems,
things like image classification,
you know, text and sound and so on.
And in all these perception problems,
you know, when you learn these models,
they're essentially
huge arrays of numbers.
That's what a model is these days,
like these deep learning models.
And they require a large
amount of data to train
and there is no easy explanation
you know, so if somebody said,
why did this model do this?
What am I going to say?
Will I say that the computer knows
how to multiply numbers correctly?
So hence it must be correct?
Because that's the best I can say today
is the model learned these numbers,
and the computer knows how to multiply.
So you know, that's it.
We think there's a better way.
So this is an example
where you use topological data analysis
to introspect into the model.
What you do is you take
those large weight matrices
that you've learned,
you throw it into the topological
data analysis framework,
and it helps you figure out
what are the base patterns
that the model has learned
and how are they connected to each other?
In fact, it also allows you
to speed up the training.
So there's a problem
in machine learning
called sample efficiency.
How much data do you need to train a model
so that you like its result?
Sample efficiency is a huge problem.
And so topological data analysis
at least in this perception
visual problem allows
you to speed up your training time
by about 4X by giving it
some topological information
about the base underlying data.